the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video in this video
i may be revealing what is likely the
official release date for house of the
dragon's very first episode now if you
know me and watch enough of my videos
then you would know that i would not
make a video about every single email
that is sent my way the only reason i'm
even making this video is because i know
this source has been accurate before
they have actually sent me several
photos during the filming of game of
thrones season 7 and game of thrones
season 8. and those photos that i
received from this email were leaks from
the game of thrones set this let me know
that whoever snapped these photos must
have worked behind the scenes with hbo
because i was able to see what was
happening in certain scenes months in
advance
so that's why i now have reason to
believe this release date for house of
the dragon will be right on the money as
well now according to this source we
will see the first episode of house of
the dragon on the 17th of april which
does happen to fall on a sunday now if
you have seen some of my recent videos
then you would know that i also thought
house of the dragon would release during
the month of april as you all know this
is also when hbo would almost always
release game of thrones as a matter of
fact 6 out of the 8 seasons of game of
thrones was released during april so i
think it does make sense that hbo would
release house of the dragon during this
month as well
now since i don't know this source very
well you still have to take this
information with a grain of salt i
obviously will not be able to confirm
this information until hbo makes their
own official announcement
so with that being said i will make this
video short and sweet but for whatever
it's worth i do think we will see house
of the dragons first episode on this
exact date that is unless of course
something happens that would make them
delay anyways let me know what you think
about this information does it line up
with the date that you had in mind or do
you think we will see the first episode
earlier than this or even much later
leave me your thoughts down below as
always i want to thank everyone for
watching this short update video i hope
all of you have a great day i will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
you